questo il gioco ragazzi si chiama top
box che vuol dire scatola sapone nel
senso che tu guidi una macchinina che
non ha il motore io l'ho fatta dal vivo
questa cosa va la faccio vedere e lo
stato molto bravo il più bravo di tutti
grazie ho fatta per red bull questa cosa
niente consiste nel guidare questa
macchina che non ha il motore e va
avanti solo perché è in discesa e ci
sono degli ostacoli e hanno fatto un
giochino più o meno realistico non è
realistico però è bello quindi bella a
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
io sono parigino ci siamo su soft boxe
game
partiamo dal presupposto che non so che
cosa sto per giocare ma va bene ragazzi
non ho ben capito dove dovrei andare
questo coso però è felice e quindi va
bene credo di essere c'è un po sfigato
del fascio esplodere credo di essere una
specie di sé è una specie di slime con
le braccia non si capisce bene ds tizio
prova per chi se ne frega let's go è un
ep uil sono molto family friendly il
credo devono andare dove doveva dotato
di è contentissimo quindi di tutti
l'obiettivo è arrivare alla fine della
mappa senza distruggersi questo è il
fatto e siccome la mappa si concatena in
vari punti mamma mia ma sto giocando
devo riuscire a farlo nella magna p
tantissimi l'assenza di atella armi per
terra però con un altro discorso mi devo
andare più ampio vorrei sempre andare
forte nei giochi però qua devo andare
piano purtroppo all'importante non
spiattellati per terra qui perfetto
perfetto pedol finish vedo il finish
vedo il fi ora è vero non ci credo
erano erano molli quei cosi io ho visto
tutti perfetto finisce leggi europee
dove devo arrivare oltre quindi non ci
sono 100 i veri e tutto fake devo
prendere ogni strada ogni volta diversa
va bene va bene di pride al primo
finisce ce l'abbiamo il secondo led
dopamina del casinò a passano di qua che
sarà di scena è brutto forse sono ancora
vivo sono gravi
non ho una nota chi se ne frega ecco non
ho più niente neanche la dignità allora
via piano piano per favore è già
difficile sul gioco per cortesia devo
andare a devo morire
morire però ho strisciato un po per
terra sono ancora a posto ce l'ho fatta
ho ripreso il controllo è vabbè è niente
mi volto sa parte veramente difficile
ragazzi tratto puoi far esplodere la
moto quando vuoi
c'è la moto la macchina da bloccare il
cos'è sta roba da bei ragazzi allora pre
grande ala destra per vedere cosa c'è di
qua perché dall'altra parte di un casino
ho capito che comunque a prescindere di
una roba
vabbè andiamo ancora ci sono un sacco di
percorsi il tuo obiettivo è cercare di
finirli tutti proprio tutti anche ne
sono un miliardo senza morire il
problema è che la macchina macchina e
senza il motore cioè tu non puoi non
puoi accelerare no tipo adesso adesso ci
arrivò in metro o verso ci posso solo
frenare praticamente senza la faccio
senza il voto no si no ho già fatta sì
dài sono più dentro e fuori lo conta
come buone un gioco in sviluppo quindi
non ti non ci sono non c'è niente non
c'è un così dice bravo ce l'hai fatta
non c'è niente quindi devo capirlo io
cosa ci hanno fatto in cui credo ce l'ho
fatta facciamo noi le regole tu questa
macchina qui solo frenare e girare non
puoi fare nient'altro
possiamo fare queste due cose stupide e
frenare quando se ne andò veloce non è
una qualità perché ti cappotti mentre
girare ecco infatti mentre sterzare
dalle parti giuste quando serve e
veramente difficile ragazzi vi giuro
però è molto carino allora il primo
percorso abbiamo fatto con la destra era
quello diritto se l'ateneo che il
secondo questa destra abbiamo fatto
prendere i diritti ma cosa succede c'è
un altro finish quanti percorsi casinò
ne hanno fatti un sacco perché fin qua
tutto bene e arrivare un finish con mio
dio quando usare il freno ecco
trovata ci ho fatto incredibile ho usato
il freno per perderà pare un casino
let's go
se ti fast and furious dominic toretto
la e questa è la pista arcobaleno di
maran di mario kart attenzione ragazzi
siamo ancora ancora ancora che la occhio
non so se la spinta
ok ce l'aveva spinta c'è la spinta
giusta per te la vita è bella quando
mori però siamo raga proprio lui proprio
lui sotto lato b qua non ci avrò mai la
spinta adeguata per far star amano
proviamoci
e invece forse sì di nuovo occhio st
parte difficile allora piano piano piano
piano per cortesia non ci credete
faccio schifo la mia vita fa schifo non
ci credo lo si no sì sì sono vivo a
posto dai va bene sono arrivato un punto
la e belli è un gioco in sviluppo ma è
bellissimo e ben fatto benissimo ci ha
fatto da cani però è divertentissimo e
quello che conta quindi va bene le
vandalico a destra c'è tutta quella
viali che io non ho preso prima però non
so come si prende mi sa che devo girare
ancora più a destra dopo un casino
eccole tronti ce la farò mai arrivarci
mai mai mai mai mai ma ci proviamo
bravo mamma mia di b che c'è abbastanza
inerzia per arrivarci proprio lui
io ho perso il pugno nel fare così fa
niente prova beh finisce bene abbiamo
totalizzati di potre va già bene da ha
distrutto la ruota la naja forse ci
arrivo forse ci arrivo alza le braccia
fendi il vento ci arrivo mamma mia con
la pista gli a destra orribile ce l'ho
fatta va bene sono contento a posto
provo ragazzi questa sinistra questa qua
a sistema la va ancora vista pavia si
prospetta uno schifo occhio
mamma mia velocità finish sono fatta non
ci credo ha posto un posto per un attimo
ho rischiato ma va bene allora vediamo
qual è quello per andare su sti cosi si
stimano in questo quadro
questa destra andiamo a destra perché lo
volevo fare da un'ora 8
mamma mia occhio a chi lo sapevo
questo deve essere veramente un casino
raga schivarli tutti un macello però
proviamo allora a patti chiari amicizia
lunga let's go eccolo eccolo manca no no
va beh no vabbè se va beh occhio fa
niente fa niente
ci abbiamo provato allora il ferro il
verde milano cava no non mi ha toccato
ma mio dio perfetto perfetto perfetto
ora il finale assurdo il piano assurdo
ci devi credere
no sì no non è vero non ci credo che è
bucio de the dead e the gelato no mi
sono salvati incredibilmente alla fine
strada ho giocate incredibili
iscrivetevi al secondo canale
mancano ancora queste che la vedo le
vedono problematiche ma va niente questo
altre scende veramente a picco e cioè il
muro a fa bene tra già l'ostacolo a
prescindere che ho schivato bravissimo
occhio sembra troppo una mappa di mario
kart che sono un po strana
cioè non sviluppata la nintendo ed
occhio occhio occhio ottico è un casino
ottiene un casinò dove vado perfetto no
ma si stupido panova dai era arrivato
tantissimo la barca vacca
ok con casinò raga con casinò qualsiasi
momento fino reggiti forte la faccio non
morire ti prego non ci voglio credere
sollevato già arrivato senso ero sulla
linea dai vale vale ho deciso io tanto
le facciamo noi le regole visto gioco
vale vale allora queste lo fate tutte
adesso l'ho fatto che l'artista l'ho
fatta adesso quella destra di qua che
cos'è è un'altra proprio
e come sono fatta ma no ma no no bravo
zio stato sto cappello inguardabile però
dove fa niente molto bravo
non so se è abbastanza sfitta invece ce
l'ho proprio lui ne manca solo una larga
teoricamente non so se poi non ho mica
qualcosa no
teoricamente ma anche solo uno sono
stato bravissimo vi do un bacino
poi vabbè cose globali pocho no vabbè
che devo fare il wall ride casino ma
vero sono fatta subito tra l'altro come
come fossi con che fisica
ma come non è neanche il motore e vabbè
ce l'ho fatta subito incredibile senza
neanche pitt ma va bè ragazzi pa vj e la
fisica sonde cosa parte mammamia ragazzo
che sta la vedo veramente incasinata ci
proviamo vamonos tra l'altro essendosi
colori tutti così accesi non vedi
neanche bene dove stai andando
e questo il casinò cioè non vedi quanto
sta continuando la pista devo farmi devo
orientarmi rispetto alle cose che vede
intorno un casino l'intero patina bravo
perfetto ma ce lo mettiamo un traguardo
prima o poi se avete voglia no ma raga
ma dura 85 anni sta pista avanti veloce
non c'è bisogno pochi ragazzi siamo
grazie al punto di prima e ho scoperto
che non era la parte di fitch è che
questa la parte difficile mamma mia
incredibile incredibile quello era il
wall ride di prima tra un casino quanto
dura sto livello 85 anni di livello da
qua vedo tutto il gioco ed è gta 5
ok ma guarda quanto dura sto livello e
dai voglio farla sporca volevano sporca
non ci credo che per una volta una mia
idea funzionato non ci voglio credere
bova e insegnate vista data perché
incredibile non ci posso credere intorno
a sorpresa da me stesso bravo fa vige
nei complimenti sono veramente sorpreso
attenzione vi dire che anche un'altra
emozione e il traguardo che non avevo
preso prima lo posso prendere adesso
eccolo ho preso anche l'altro non so
come ho fatto a trovare questo gioco
forse dovrei trovarmi una ragazza però è
un altro discorso però che vi sia
piaciuto ragazzi
lasciate un bel like se vi è piaciuto
consigliato i giochi del genere anche se
sono più o meno introvabili trovo io
perché sono un po fuori di testa
iscrivetevi al canale schiacciate la
campanella che vedete qui sotto per
ricevere le notifiche dei prossimi video
fatelo perché sono non vi arrivano e vi
pare tv dobelli e noi come sempre ci
vediamo l'anno prossimo video per
ragazzi
[Musica]